bonjour à tous Monsieur Madame
merci d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui donc
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie des
médicaments et le choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française en audition en
auditionnant donc les représentants que
vous êtes de la Mission
interministérielle sur les mécanismes de
régulation et de financement des
produits de santé dont l'installation
est assez récente puisqu'elle a été
annoncée par la première ministre en
janvier dernier soit quelques jours
avant la constitution de notre propre
commission d'enquête le 1er février donc
les calendriers de nos travaux
respectifs
coïncides donc presque exactement et
alors que vous devez rendre votre
rapport si je ne m'abuse en la fin du
mois de juillet il me semble d'après la
lettre de mission
quelques semaines après un autre donc il
était naturel que nous vous entendions
d'autant que vous si vous étiez chargé
d'après la lettre de mission de formuler
des premières pistes sous trois mois
donc a priori fin avril alors je sais
que ça posait peut-être problème que
vous soyez auditionné de votre point de
vue mais pour nous c'est important et
comme
on peut on peut aussi échanger sur le
niveau de vos réflexions de
d'aujourd'hui donc la question de la
régulation économique du médicament est
en effet apparue au fil de nombreuses
auditions publiques que nous avons
conduites comme un volet essentiel de
toute réflexion sur les voies et moyens
d'une lutte efficace et victorieuse
contre les tensions d'approvisionnement
et les pénuries phénomène qui est devenu
malheureusement endémique dans notre
pays depuis pratiquement une décennie
installé alors que la feuille de route
[Musique]
2019-2022 avait vécu sa mise en oeuvre
ayant été ralentie pour ne pas dire
compromise par cette autre crise
sanitaire que nous avons tous traversés
celle de du covid-19 ou de la covid-19
et votre mission a précisément pour
tâche de faire ce que la feuille de
route ne faisait pas à savoir s'attaquer
aux racines du problème de
l'indisponibilité chronique en France de
certains médicaments essentiels et si en
effet les grands axes de la feuille de
route étaient exclusivement d'ordre
organisationnel et infernational il
s'agit désormais non plus seulement de
gérer les pénuries mais en amont d'en
prévenir purement et simplement
l'apparition en tout cas nous c'est
aussi dans cet esprit là que nous
travaillons à cette fin vous avez été
explicitement chargé de travailler au
modalités concrètes d'activisation de
ces leviers de nature économique et
industriel que sont la relocalisation de
la production des médicaments les plus
critiques le renforcement de notre tissu
productif la reconquête de notre
souveraineté sanitaire qui sont un peu
les trois axes sur lesquels on travaille
vous avez été chargé de réfléchir
corrélativement à une éventuelle refonte
de la politique de prix administrée qui
fait la spécificité du médicament ce
bien proprement hors du commun qui n'est
pas une marchandise comme les autres et
même pas marchandise sa tarification
fait en effet depuis longtemps l'objet
de vivre débat qu'il s'agisse de
déplorer le prix exorbitant de certains
produits innovants ou de critiquer les
effets délétères des économies demandées
aux exploitants de spécialité qui bien
qu'en sienne reste essentiel dans
l'arsenal thérapeutique de nos médecins
sur toutes ces questions nous
souhaitions recueillir vos premières
conclusions et les confronter aux pistes
qui nous ont permis de dégager de notre
côté quatre mois de d'enquête
d'auditions durant lesquelles nous avons
essayé de de vrai à un décloisonnement
de la réflexion et des politiques
publiques du médicament trop souvent
mené en silo en tout cas c'est un des
enseignements que nous avons tirés nous
recevons donc nous vous recevons donc
cet après-midi deux en tant que
représentant deux sur parmi 6 auquel la
première ministre a confié cette cette
mission d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé que cette
commission était très largement féminine
dans la composition donc Madame Magali
Léo désignait en tant que responsable du
plaidoyer au sein d'une association de
patients et en l'occurrence des patients
atteints de maladies rénales chroniques
l'association renalou dont nous avons
par ailleurs auditionné fondatrice et
présidente le 1er mars dernier vous êtes
également membre du comité d'information
sur les produits de santé de la NSM et
du conseil de la CNAM mais aussi quoi
qu'en réserve durant le temps de la
mission membre du bord de next step qui
est le cabinet de conseil en affaires
publiques spécialisée dans le domaine de
la santé Monsieur Frédéric collet vous
avez été désigné en tant ambassadeur
France 2030 vous avez surtout été de
2017 à 2022 président de Novartis France
et de mars 2019 à juin 2022 président du
LEM l'organisation professionnelle
représentative des grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques opérants en France et
que nous avons bien entendu auditionner
je vous remercie Madame Monsieur de vous
être mobilisé il importait évidemment
que je précise d'où exactement vous
parlez des critiques c'est en
régulièrement exprimé depuis de la
mission sur sa composition et notamment
sur l'absence en son sein de
représentants de professionnels de santé
on ira peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
je vais donc vous céder la parole pour
un bref propos introductif puis Laurence
Cohen notre rapporteur vous posera une
première série de questions et ensuite
les collègues qui sont là
en ajoutant je précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site d'internet internet du Sénat et
qu'elle fera bien entendu l'objet d'une
d'un compte rendu publié et avant de
vous donner la parole je vous rappelle
que nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
commission d'enquête et qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission et
passible de peine prévue aux articles
434 13 434 434 15 du code pénal je
précise également qu'il vous appartient
le cas échéant échéant d'indiquer vos
éventuels liens d'intérêt ou conflit
d'intérêt
en relation avec l'objet de la
commission d'enquête d'enquête je vous
invite donc à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure donc Madame Léo tout d'abord je le
jure
et Monsieur collet
merci et vous avez la parole
madame la vice-présente madame la
rapporteur madame messieurs merci de
nous permettre cette audition et ce
temps de partage sur les travaux à date
de la mission
peut-être quelques propos introductifs
autour du cadre et vous l'avez mentionné
madame la Présidente très large de la
mission la lettre de mission qui nous a
été adressée qu'on porte une série de
volets qui portent sur des sujets très
variés mais tous liés autour de l'accès
aux médicaments et des dispositifs
médicaux donc c'est une mission qui
porte à la fois sur le la régulation et
le financement des médicaments et des
dispositifs médicaux effectivement
initiative de madame la Première
ministre une lettre de mission que nous
avons reçue en janvier 2023 et dont
les pénuries sont un thème un thème qui
effectivement en lien avec d'autres
sujets liés à la régulation et au
financement de la santé mais qui n'est
pas un thème exclusif notre les travaux
de la mission ne portent pas
exclusivement sur le sujet il y a des
pénuries
nos travaux interviennent dans un
contexte qui est critique qui a à la
fois marqué par de fortes contraintes
sanitaires sociales environnementale
géopolitique et environnementales donc
c'est dans ce champ de contraintes que
nous devons évoluer et faire des
propositions sensées et cohérentes
notre objet donc bien de faire des
propositions qui s'appuient sur un bilan
et des éléments diagnostiques partagés
étayés par des données des données
auxquelles nous avons pu avoir accès qui
nécessitent un gros travail de suivi et
d'analyse et le l'objectif est
effectivement d'assurer d'une part les
conditions d'accès aux soins d'autre
part l'attractivité l'autonomie
industrielle de notre pays et enfin la
compatibilité budgétaire de ces mesures
dans ce contexte nouveau et
particulièrement perturbé par la crise
sanitaire
à la demande de Madame la première
ministre nous travaillons donc sur le
sur un bilan général de la situation en
particulier sur l'impact des leviers de
de régulation
nous allons faire des propositions sur
l'évolution de ces dispositifs de
régulation en abordant notamment les
questions de la contribution à
l'efficience des soins des solutions
innovantes leurs tarification mais aussi
et c'est très important pour nous les
sujets liés à la juste prescription et à
la pertinence des soins
nous envisageons également de faire le
point sur la gouvernance et notamment la
question de la plurianualité la gestion
pluriannuelle des dépenses d'assurance
d'Assurance Maladie pardon et puis
évidemment d'aborder la question du
soutien l'innovation son accès sa
contribution et son financement sans
oublier la contribution européenne à ces
travaux qui doit être également
considéré dans le cadre d'une
comparaison internationale
donc comme vous voyez la question des
ruptures et des tensions
d'approvisionnement n'est pas
directement au coeur de notre vaste
sujet mais elle est toutefois plusieurs
fois citée dans la lettre de mission et
donc nous l'expertisons au même titre
que les autres problématiques
sur la composition de la mission
quelques mots puisque effectivement vous
avez lu et vous l'avez fait remarquer
les premières critiques qui ont été
formulées à l'occasion de la mise en
place de notre mission donc nous
constituons un comité d'experts qualifié
dans des domaines complémentaires nous
sommes tous fortement engagés et ceux
depuis de nombreuses années sur les
sujets liés à la santé nous avons tous
un même engagement personnel dans nos
parcours pour défendre l'accès à tous
les patients
au traitement qui leur sont indiqués
dans le respect du contrat social la
nature et la qualité de nos débats
confirment cette diversité et cette
complémentarité de nos expertises et de
nos parcours je pourrais si vous le
souhaitez vous dire un mot peut-être de
de
de biographie sur chacun des des membres
de la mission pour ma part je précise
que je ne fais plus partie du comité
d'information des produits de santé de
la NSM et je ne fais plus non plus
partie du conseil de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie et que effectivement
madame la vice-présidente comme vous
l'avez souligné je suis déportée sur mon
mandat au sein du board de la dizaine à
bord de next step pendant le temps de la
mission
sur le fonctionnement peut-être un mot
puisque c'est un travail très exigeant
qui nous occupe beaucoup
peut-être même beaucoup plus qu'on ne le
pensait a priori nous effectuons
beaucoup de recherches nous réalisons
beaucoup d'auditions plus d'une centaine
à ce jour plus de 110 me semble-t-il
nous avons encore une série d'auditions
qui qui est prévue et nous engageons des
réflexions de façon collégiale avec
l'absence de de Lead d'un des d'un des
des personnes qualifiées pardon sur les
autres donc nous sommes sur un des
travaux qui sont extrêmement collégiaux
avec beaucoup de co-construction et de
réflexion collective nos travaux sont en
cours et c'est important de se le redire
donc aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas
nous ne serons pas en mesure de vous
présenter nos pistes et c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
souhaité remettre de rapport
intermédiaire en avril le travail est
long et lent
est compliqué
est assez tentaculaire
nécessite la prise en compte des avis de
plusieurs parties prenantes et elles
sont très nombreuses
parties prenantes que nous avons
sollicité mais aussi qui se rapproche
spontanément de notre mission pour être
auditionné nous avons besoin d'entendre
nous avons besoin de consacrer du temps
à l'écoute de l'ensemble de ces parties
prenantes et nous ne saurons pas
aujourd'hui en mesure de vous de vous
préciser les pistes sur lesquelles nous
travaillons à ceci près que nous pouvons
évidemment poser quelques éléments de
cadrage et des grandes orientations sur
lesquelles nous pourrons revenir
au titre des personnes et organisations
qui ont été auditionnées par notre
mission il y a bien sûr les
administrations nous avons passé
beaucoup de temps avec plusieurs d'entre
elles je pense notamment au CEPS mais
pas seulement nous avons évidemment
auditionner les organisations qui
représentent les patients ou les usagers
du système de santé d'ailleurs nous
rencontrons également par ailleurs au
titre de la démocratie en santé le
président de la Conférence nationale de
santé
les acteurs industriels bien sûr à
travers leurs syndicat S et puis les
principaux acteurs industriels et
économiques de la chaîne des produits de
santé
des acteurs du soin et en particulier
professionnel de santé des médecins les
pharmaciens des économistes des experts
des experts des données mais aussi de la
prospective et de l'environnement de la
santé
voilà donc comme je vous l'ai dit nous
consacrons beaucoup de temps à l'analyse
des données qui sont produites par les
parties prenantes pas seulement de
l'administration mais nous avons reçu
aussi des des liasses de données très
intéressantes du côté des industriels et
des associations de patients que nous
expertisons
et les débats de ce comité se font
régulièrement en son sein ne
recommandations seront uniquement
adressé au nom de notre mission et
rédiger de façon co-construite
nos recommandations n'étant pas
finalisées voilà nous souhaitons encore
aujourd'hui prendre le temps et nous en
avons encore un peu puisque nous devons
effectivement remettre notre rapport
définitif à la fin du mois de juillet ce
qui ne nous empêche évidemment pas
d'échanger régulièrement avec les
différents cabinets
voilà je laisse peut-être après ce
propos liminaire
je veux je vous remercie et
effectivement je n'avais pas mesuré à
quel point nos travaux étaient
parallèles et donc effectivement
j'imagine que vous avez vous aussi
auditionné beaucoup de gens sur ce
secteur en général probablement en étant
plus concentré sur la question des
pénuries mais le spectre vous le voyez
de la démission qui nous a été confié
est extrêmement large et il est
effectivement comme le souligne Magali
difficile après plus de 100 auditions et
sans auditions quelquefois qui ont été
répétées donc ce sont pas 200 heures
d'entretien que nous avons eu au moins
mais encore de faire cette synthèse
compte tenu des changements auxquels
nous sont face peut-être deux constats
pour pour commencer le premier c'est que
l'attention on est frappé par
l'attention extrêmement forte que
suscite notre travail de la part de tous
les acteurs que nous rencontrons nous
sommes beaucoup sollicités nous sentons
à quel point il y a une attente de la
part de tous qu'il soit acteur de
l'administration qu'il soit acteur
industriel qu'il soit spécialiste qu'il
soit bien sûr acteurs de santé qu'il
soit représentant des patients nous
sommes énormes extrêmement sollicités et
nous mesurons à quel point il y a une
attente sur nos travaux avec qui nous
espérons ne pas décevoir mais à quel
point l'attente est forte la deuxième
le deuxième point qui est important
c'est que on est très frappé de la le
terme est peut-être pas adéquate mais de
la volonté de bien faire de tous les
gens qu'on rencontre c'est-à-dire que la
santé certainement un environnement qui
tend dans l'administration que dans les
que les chez les professionnels de santé
mais également dans l'industrie et fait
de gens qui sont très engagés et qui ont
une réelle volonté de bien faire
quelquefois en gérant des injonctions
quelquefois paradoxales mais ça nous a
beaucoup frappé
alors peut-être que au-delà de quelques
remarques
on observe d'une part deux choses la
première c'est qu'il y a un constat très
convergent sur le fait que la situation
est à bout de souffle enfin que le
contexte compte tenu des éléments
peut-être que sur lequel je vais revenir
étape à bout de souffle en revanche ce
qui est assez normal les propositions
les solutions les initiatives les idées
les suggestions divergent compte tenues
des acteurs et ça c'est très attendu
mais certainement le constat est celui
d'une situation qui ne fonctionne plus
telle qu'elle est alors peut-être
on peut pas que je peux partager
quelques quelques éléments de ce que
nous observons à ce stade la première
c'est que il y a une rupture extrêmement
forte et inédite depuis je serai pas là
où nous serions pas la taille mais
comment dire la préciser dans le temps
de façon parfaite mais disons de deux
ans et depuis 2 ans alors vous allez me
dire c'est probable c'est pas c'est le
l'effet du covid et non ce n'est pas
uniquement la crise sanitaire la crise
sanitaire a fonctionné comme un
accélérateur comme un révélateur mais ce
que nous observons n'est pas liés
directement à la crise sanitaire qui en
est un des éléments mais qui n'est pas
le seul et donc nous observons une vraie
rupture depuis deux ans alors les
éléments où vous les avez entendus vous
les connaissez mais c'est certainement
d'abord un phénomène démographique avec
vieillissement de la population c'est il
y a aucun doute épidémiologique avec
effectivement des des personnes qu'on
accompagne beaucoup plus longtemps avec
des maladies notamment avec des maladies
chroniques
la tension sur les prix
qui a toujours été toujours été là et
singulièrement en France
a été accentuée avec les effets de
l'inflation c'est-à-dire que l'inflation
qui juste là a été contenue ne jouait
pas tellement sur les condexploitation
des entreprises et notamment sur la
rentabilité de certains produits voire
de certaines entreprises aujourd'hui
l'effet de l'inflation se fait ressentir
d'une façon nouvelle et touche le
secteur que met en touche d'autres avec
comme vous l'avez souligné la question
de prix régulier qui est un facteur tout
à fait spécifique à ce secteur
et puis on observe en parallèle et bien
entendu vous le savez à resserrement qui
est très fort de la de la contrainte
budgétaire
avec là un impact positrice qui est
évident et particulièrement en France ou
en tout cas 5 certainement en France et
puis au-delà de ça je pense que un
phénomène ancien et qui continue de
durer sur une sorte de désaffection ou
une crise de l'attractivité industrielle
et qui est qui est présente la
conséquence de tout ça est que c'est
évidemment une tension sur les plans sur
le plan sanitaire et budgétaire qui est
véritablement sans précédent avec des
outils qui aujourd'hui en écoutant les
différents acteurs nous semblent très
nous semble inadaptés véritablement
inadapté au contexte et la manifestation
la plus évidente de ça c'est le rythme
de croissance de la dépense réelle et
tendancielle qui n'est
pas soutenable et ni connecté avec celle
de l'âme donc on a véritablement
une question budgétaire face à une
question économique et selon le terme
que nous employons permettez-moi
l'expression une difficulté à faire
rentrer les dredons dans la machine dans
la valise c'est à dire que on mesure à
quel point l'équation est devenue
aujourd'hui extrêmement complexe
si l'on souhaite préserver comme c'est
notre objectif
l'accès à tous les patients français au
traitement dont ils ont besoin en toute
circonstances
ce qu'il est important de souligner
c'est que les tensions que nous
observons et les celles que j'ai
évoquées en particulier
sont des tensions internationales pour
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire que tous les
pays peu ou Prous font face au même
difficulté que ce soit des que ce soit
des questions démographiques que ce soit
des questions budgétaires que ce soit
bien sûr des questions épidémiologiques
et des questions de l'innovation et tous
ces sujets là sont partagés
le deuxième point c'est qu'effectivement
bon je vais pas revenir dessus mais on a
une sorte avec cette
internationalisation dont j'ai parlé un
changement des conditions d'accès et
même du rapport entre les acteurs avec
une très forte évolution des volumes de
soins consommés dans le monde en général
moins en France parce que là et dans
d'autres pays mais la France est un pays
qui a contenu non seulement la dépense
de santé par patient par les prix mais
également en volume relativement en
unité consommée une force tension sur
l'esprit j'aimerais pas que le propos
liminaire soit limité à un constat qu'on
a qu'on a fait donc essentiellement de
prendre les points essentiels de votre
statut sans aller dans les détails parce
que c'est des choses qu'on que vous
connaissent travail depuis et on
reviendra avec les questions mais ce
qu'il faut privilégier l'échange vous
avez raison donc le constat qu'on a déjà
qu'on connaît
le troisième point que je voulais
souligner c'est celui de un certain
nombre de ce qui est beaucoup de ces
éléments sont des éléments partagés
entre différents pays en revanche on est
face à une un héritage de soins
stratégiques et politiques qui sont
peut-être distinctes ce qui ont été
effectués dans d'autres pays avec pour
faire très simple une régulation en
France qui s'est principalement appuyé
sur une régulation par les prix et par
la valeur historique si on regarde les
différents budgets et avec succès le
long dame a été contenu maintenu depuis
des années à contrario les deux autres
leviers que sur le levier sur les
volumes c'est-à-dire le volume de
produits consommés a été moins activé
que ce qu'on peut observer dans d'autres
pays et en particulier la façon dont la
prescription médicale et
encadré si on peut dire le terme et
moins activé que ce qu'elle peut être
dans d'autres pays et également ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'effet de structure et
notamment la façon dont le générique et
le BIOS similaire sont eux aussi
optimisés
c'est-à-dire que en comparaison d'autres
pays on est aussi étonné de voir à quel
point ce sont des réserves de
d'économies qui peuvent être aujourd'hui
mieux utilisés mieux exploiter
et dernier sujet sur ce point puisque
dans les choix qui ont été fait la
question environnementale est une
question qui nous préoccupe dont on a
peu parlé effectivement mais qui fait
partie de la lettre et qui est
aujourd'hui un point important puisque
10% de l'empreinte carbone en France
enfin de la et provient du secteur de la
santé donc c'est un sujet qui doit nous
préoccuper
enfin le le dernier point c'est
qu'effectivement c'est le système est
aujourd'hui sous une tension extrême je
pense que elle nous pensons que elle
appelle des choix politiques et
collectifs qui sont forts pour justement
préserver l'accès au traitement et
optimiser la contribution de ces
traitements là ça passe par plusieurs
choses ça passe certainement par une
meilleure maîtrise médicalisée c'est ce
qui nous semble ça passe également
probablement par une meilleure
exploitation des réserves de d'économies
que nous avons ça passe également par
une meilleure captation de ce que enfin
une meilleure identification et
meilleure suivie de ce que les
traitements innovants peuvent apporter
au système de santé sur lequel notamment
la médico-éco ne répond pas suffisamment
et le suivi dans le temps que nous avons
ne parvient pas suffisamment à répondre
et enfin un système général dans lequel
il est la croissance même de ce secteur
doit être doit être envisagée et puis
enfin je termine avec ce point un
système de régulation et de financement
extrêmement complexe vous êtes vous en
êtes des experts très mal compris qui
suscite des critiques parfois même
violentes de la part des différents
acteurs quels qu'ils soient et notamment
une grande incompréhension une grande
incompréhension pour les patients et
pour les professionnels de santé qui ne
comprennent pas comment dans la même
journée ils peuvent faire partie des 4
millions de personnes qui visitent une
pharmacie à qui on dit l'amoxicilline
n'est pas disponible mais également lire
à la une du Parisien par exemple que
certains traitements anticancéreux ne
sont pas disponibles en France quand ils
le sont ailleurs donc on sent cette
tension qui n'est plus simplement une
tension d'expert du sujet mais une
tension qui touche plus généralement les
acteurs et qui nécessitent également
qu'on revoit du coup le le
comment dire le partage d'informations
la symétrie d'information mais également
la façon de représenter mieux les
patients dans cet environnement et de
mieux les intégrer aux questions qui
sont abordées voilà ce que je peux vous
dire en quelques mots et je vous prie de
m'excuser si j'étais trop long merci non
c'est pas que mais c'est vrai que ça
correspond à des choses que que nous on
serait capable de tout ce qui est du
domaine du constat et donc ce qui nous
intéresse c'est d'aller un peu plus loin
sur sur les explications même si vous
aurez vous aurez quelques retenus vous
nous l'avez annoncé je passe la parole à
notre rapporteur Laurence Cohen
oui merci Madame merci Monsieur
effectivement vous en êtes resté quand
même assez sur un propos généraliste de
constat que nous avons pu
[Musique]
partager depuis le début de nos
auditions
je voudrais moi abonder dans le sens de
ce qu'a dit la présidence parce que
effectivement la composition quand même
de votre de votre
collectif pose pose problème c'est à
dire que par rapport à l'indépendance
que vous pouvez avoir à l'égard du
secteur de l'industrie pharmaceutique
parce que vous êtes vous êtes 6 et quand
même les 6 sont des liens d'intérêt où
ont eu des liens d'intérêt importants
donc c'est quand même quelque chose que
je veux porter à nouveau parce que ça
n'est pas anodin dans le contexte de la
mission ça c'est plus une réflexion
qu'une question ensuite dans les
remarques très généralistes que vous
avez bien voulu partager avec nous en
fait à aucun moment
vous vous n'interrogez me semble-t-il ou
en tout cas pas suffisamment ou on a
besoin d'avoir des précisions le modèle
économique c'est à dire parler par
exemple d'une meilleure maîtrise
médicalisée c'est effectivement un
élément mais un élément parmi beaucoup
d'autres et pas et certainement pas
l'élément qui paraît essentiel en tout
cas au fil des auditions que nous avons
pu avoir on est dans une situation où
effectivement les pénuries de
médicaments
touchent l'ensemble des pays avec plus
ou moins de vivacité on va dire que la
France est particulièrement touchée et
que malheureusement on a vu au fil du
temps
des médicaments de plus en plus nombreux
à être touché c'est-à-dire que là et ce
qui a mis je pense le public
dans la boucle si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi c'est que ça a touché des
médicaments qui étaient d'usage plus
courant et notamment tout ce qui
concernait la pédiatrie ou là ça a
entraîné à juste titre beaucoup beaucoup
des mois mais on voit enfin nous on a
été saisis il y a eu également la pilule
amortie enfin il y a toutes les classes
thérapeutiques sont touchées donc on
peut on ne peut pas ne pas interroger
notre système économique depuis 30 ans
il y a eu une politique de
délocalisation des entreprises pour une
question de rentabilité financière donc
il y a eu une recherche d'aller dans des
pays à moindre coût au niveau social et
au niveau environnemental aujourd'hui
les exigences sont différentes et il y a
un appel de la France à relocaliser un
certain nombre d'industries
pharmaceutiques notamment puisque c'est
ce qui nous c'est ce qui nous concerne
cette relocalisation ne peut pas se
faire uniquement les champs de la France
ce serait ridicule personne d'ailleurs
ne le dit donc il y a une réflexion une
coordination à avoir au niveau européen
au moins pour le moins donc
quelle réflexion
avez-vous déjà
sur sur ce questionnement précis ça
c'est c'est ma première interrogation ma
deuxième interrogation c'est que on nous
dit et notamment les industriels que les
les
produits matures sont particulièrement
bas et que ça serait ça qui expliquerait
les pénuries or là encore nous avons eu
de nombreuses auditions et nous avons vu
que dans d'autres pays où les les
médicaments sont un prix plus haut je
pense par exemple à la Suisse les
pénuries sont tout aussi nombreuses
voire plus donc ça n'est pas suffisant
les causes sont plurifactorielles ce
serait trop simple si on avait qu'une
donc il y a aussi bon mais peut-être que
ce qui nous en tout cas nous intéresse
au moment de notre puisque nous allons
rendre notre rapport début juillet c'est
d'avoir des éléments plus précis
justement sur cette
cette régulation au niveau au niveau des
prix vous avez parlé mais extrêmement
brièvement de la clause de sauvegarde la
clause de sauvegarde effectivement
le problème de cette de ce disposiste de
ce mécanisme c'est qu'il est en fait il
est pas obligatoirement prévisible par
rapport aux
industriels ils vont savoir après coup
la somme qu'ils auront à débourser mais
là encore nous faisons une différence
entre les grands labos qu'on les rend
plus solides et qui ont dégagé
d'ailleurs des des milliards d'euros et
puis les petites PME qui elle ou les PME
c'est d'ailleurs la peine de dire petite
PME ou qui elles sont plus en difficulté
est-ce qu'il y a vous avez une réflexion
concernant donc cette cette clause cette
clause de sauvegarde est-ce que par
exemple vous avez parmi vos pistes
étudier le fait que peut-être qu'il
faudrait sortir les lui mature est-ce
que c'est nécessaire est-ce que c'est
indispensable ce que non ça serait pas
ça serait pas une une idée qui pourrait
aider justement à faire en sorte de
combattre de combattre les pénuries une
troisième question c'est que le
législateur a ajouté un critère de
fixation du prix des médicaments qui
tient à la sécurité d'approvisionnement
du marché français que garantit
l'implantation des sites de production
c'est ce qu'on appelle le critère
industriel est-ce que ce bonus doit
selon vous s'appliquer aux médicaments
innovants comme aux médicaments mature
et enfin ma dernière question qui est
liée c'est que le CEPS a élaboré une
doctrine qui ne vise l'application du
critère industriel coproduit
nouvellement inscrits est-ce que
finalement vous pensez que c'est une
bonne
doctrine ou est-ce que ça ne rate pas la
cible du législateur justement en
excluant les produits matures qui
concentrent l'essentiel des difficultés
d'approvisionnement donc voilà les
premières questions que j'ai envie de
vous poser en insistant quand même sur
le fait que la plupart enfin la majorité
des pénuries touche plutôt les les
produits matures et que nous avons vu et
nous avons tous et toutes étaient
choqués par l'envoler d'un certain
nombre de traitements dit innovants qui
dépasse enfin je veux dire cette course
terrible à des prix pharaoniques ne va
pas pouvoir perdurer
merci vous avez la parole
merci Madame la rapporteur pour vos
questions alors je on va on va vous
répondre tous les deux mais je peux
commencer peut-être à apporter quelques
premiers éléments
sans commenter peut-être les liens
d'intérêt des membres de notre mission
juste rappeler et on se tient à votre
disposition pour apporter plus de
précision si vous le souhaitez mais que
beaucoup de membres de notre mission ont
des carrières dans le privé mais ont eu
précédemment des des grandes carrières
aussi dans le public et dans voilà avec
des missions
importantes au niveau des différentes
directions ministérielles
et que voilà ce qui nous rassemble c'est
aussi notre engagement notre expertise
et quant au choix et à la composition de
la mission
elle-même je pense que c'est une
question qu'il faudrait adresser au
cabinet de la Première ministre
elle-même puisque c'est elle qui a fait
le choix et qui a approché les personnes
qualifiées que nous sommes pour ma part
j'ai accepté assez vite et avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme de faire partie de cette
mission aux côtés de mes collègues
puisque je considère qu'effectivement il
y a un enjeu social extrêmement fort et
je connais le niveau d'engagement des
associations de patients sur les
différents thèmes de la mission donc
c'était très important à titre personnel
de de d'en faire partie et de porter la
voix des patients
alors je pense que vous adressez un
sujet qui est majeur madame Cohen autour
du modèle économique bien sûr et
d'ailleurs c'est l'un des attendus de la
mission bien sûr que nous l'interrogons
bien sûr qu'il est au cœur de tous les
de toutes les mesures que nous
expertisons et les propositions que nous
sommes en train d'analyser pour nous le
modèle économique qui repose en effet
sur la régulation des volumes de
nouveaux mécanismes autour du prix et
puis également des l'évolution et je
n'ajouteur pas grand chose par rapport à
ce qui est écrit à la lettre de mission
effectivement l'évolution de ces outils
de régulation qui sont datés voire
dépassés on peut le on peut le dire qui
aujourd'hui montrent que notre système
est à bout de souffle avec un niveau de
dépenses de santé qui va probablement
plus être soutenable si on poursuit sur
ce tendance
d'innovation ou en tout cas voilà une
vague d'innovation qui arrive qui seront
probablement associés à des prix élevés
et donc qu'il faut voilà imaginer et
peut voir dans un écosystème complexe
notre système de santé effectivement il
est il est nettement fragilisé par les
nouveaux considérants et les nouveaux
éléments de conteste que Frédéric a cité
mais que vous connaissez par cœur dans
un contexte inflationniste qui ne
faciliterait rien donc oui je pense
d'ailleurs que si cette mission nous a
été confiée c'est pour que nous
réfléchissions sans dogmatisme sans
limite d'ailleurs enfin je veux dire
voilà on s'autorise parfois à aller
assez loin et à être assez disruptif
dans les propositions que nous ont la
maîtrise médicalisée pour nous assez
centrale
parmi les éléments de la régulation et
du nouveau modèle économique puisqu'il y
a quand même un vrai sujet autour des
volumes de prescriptions des volumes de
médicaments consommés
ces variables selon les classes
thérapeutiques mais enfin nous sommes
quand même des très gros consommateurs
parmi les plus importants en Europe de
médicaments donc il y a un vrai sujet
autour de la sobriété des prescriptions
en France il n'y a que 23% la
prescription qui nous donne lieu à une
une prescription sans médicament voilà
une ordonnance de non prescription alors
que c'est 70% en Suède par exemple ce
n'est qu'un exemple mais qui montre que
on a un vrai sujet autour de la culture
du médicament dans notre pays donc pour
nous c'est essentiel de travailler sur
sur les volumes mais ça ne culte pas les
sujets très épineux très sensibles et
très complexes autour du prix je
laisserai peut-être Frédéric compléter
mais nous avons effectivement une une
analyse assez poussée sur le montant m
et la clause de sauvegarde qui
effectivement est là sans aller trop
loin sur l'analyse mais dont les effets
sont dénoncés justement par leur manque
de prévisibilité vous avez raison de de
le souligner et qui surtout a été un
dispositif qui a été prévu pour être un
rattrapage
une solution de dernier recours et non
pas comme un mécanisme de régulation a
priori ce qu'elle ce qu'il est en train
de devenir donc nous sommes
effectivement en train de d'y réfléchir
et de d'imaginer une refonte d'un
système que nous voulons plus vertueux
qui ne décourage pas l'A ccès aux
innovations qui ne décourage pas non
plus l'accès précoce des patients aux
innovations c'est un point extrêmement
important et nous sommes sur une ligne
de crête un équilibre compliqué à
trouver
voilà je laisse peut-être
deux fois vous avez posé la question de
vous avez posé la question européenne
qui est évidemment un enjeu on voit que
d'autres pays notamment
le marché du
de la santé à plus de 40% 45%
construit aux États-Unis le poids des
États-Unis très important les décisions
qui s'y appliquent s'y appliquent de
façon uniforme l'Europe est encore assez
morcelée alors le repas ça forme de
succès derrière elle que sont en
particulier l'AMM que vous aujourd'hui
on est en train d'avancer sur
l'évaluation avec l'acheta en commençant
par le cancer avec une volonté
d'harmoniser cette évaluation ce qui est
très bien après ça la crise covid a
aussi nous a aussi appris un certain
nombre de choses notamment dans la
capacité de l'Europe à se mobiliser sur
des causes communes évidemment notamment
dans le cadre du vaccin et donc un de
nos points effectivement de regarder
s'il y a des possibilités de de mieux
coordonner l'action européenne pour
assurer en particulier
l'approvisionnement et l'accès sur
certains traitements mais c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui que nous avons la question
que vous posez après est celle de la
clause de sauvegarde
je pense que vous avez entendu beaucoup
de gens ici vous parlez de la clause de
sauvegarde et du fait que le mécanisme
vous faites a perdu son esprit d'origine
l'esprit d'origine la clause de
sauvegarde était d'être un mécanisme
d'absorption aujourd'hui c'est devenu
c'est de contenu de l'écart entre la
croissance naturelle et la croissance
régulée la clause de sauvegarde prend
une dimension qui est tout à fait
nouvelle la clos de sauvegarde elle
présente un certain nombre de
difficultés dont une forte iniquité que
vous avez souligné c'est à dire que
globalement l'ensemble du secteur va
contribuer à la clause de sauvegarde de
façon uniforme donc nous réfléchissons
aujourd'hui à la façon de faire en sorte
que la clause de sauvegarde conserve son
esprit d'origine et que pour autant on
garde une régulation il est pas question
de aucun d'entre nous ne recommande que
que le système ne soit pas sous contrôle
et que les dépenses de santé ne soient
pas contrôlées et donc c'est aujourd'hui
un travail que nous faisons entre
l'adaptation et le respect de la clause
de sauvegarde dans son esprit d'origine
et en même temps la façon dont on peut
activer d'autres leviers et peut-être
comme vous l'avez souligné de de la de
l'ajuster pour la rendre moins
inéquitable quand elle existe la
quatrième question que vous avez posée
et celle de la sécurité des des
approvisionnements et du critère
industriel qui s'applique de la même
façon pour des médicaments matures et
les médicaments innovants si j'ai bien
compris votre votre question
les critères industriels s'appliquent de
façon différente selon qu'il s'agisse de
médicaments matures et innovants c'est
un sujet sur lequel le
on a sur lequel on n'a pas tranché en
effet effectivement l'enjeu l'enjeu le
tissu que nous avons en France et que
vous connaissez est un tissu qui est
fait de deux types de type d'entreprises
très très différentes des entreprises
souvent françaises avec un empreinte
industrielle en France qui est très
forte et qu'il faut chercher à préserver
souvent ce sont des entreprises qui sont
pour la majorité d'entre elles
positionnées sur des produits matures
dont il faut préserver la le les
conditions de vie et d'équilibre à
l'autre bout vous avez les plus les plus
innovantes sont souvent des entreprises
internationales
pas systématiquement mais souvent des
entreprises internationales et pour la
plupart avec des empreintes
industrielles qui sont moins fortes donc
la question est de se dire comment
est-ce qu'on peut travailler sur les
unes et les autres sans en ne s'appuyant
pas strictement que sur l'aspect
industrielle et
la question des pénuries est une
question qui est d'abord elle est pas
nouvelle vous vous en êtes saisis c'est
une question qui est là depuis moi j'ai
depuis au moins une dizaine d'années
elle prend une amplitude nouvelle
aujourd'hui elle est comme vous l'avez
soulignée d'abord elle est
internationale elle a des causes
différentes il y a eu beaucoup de de
missions de sujets de comment dire
d'action diverses qui ont été menées et
je pense que effectivement la
reconnaissance industrielle est à des
sujets mais ce sera pas le seul
j'avoue qu'on est un petit peu
interpellé par le type d'échange qu'on a
parce qu'on se rend compte quand même
que
et on peut le comprendre que que vous
voulez pas aller plus loin dans dans vos
futurs préconisations et que du coup on
reste un peu sur des sur des généralités
que il y a un blocage sur les questions
de fond qu'on d'abord madame Léo quand
la rapporteur dit que il y a un problème
de composition c'est pas ça remet pas en
cause la conviction personnelle de
chacun des membres c'est pas ça c'est
pas ça le problème le problème c'est que
on est toujours le produit culturel de
son propre parcours et que donc quand on
a dans une commission des parcours qui
qui finalement sont relativement
semblables et ne couvre pas le champ on
a de fortes chances d'avoir finalement
des des réponses qui sont des réponses
biaisées quelque part c'est pas ça remet
absolument pas en cause l'engagement
personnel de chacun et vous le comprend
vous le comprendrez aisément et du coup
quand moi j'entends quand vous nous
dites que finalement
dans la fin de votre propos liminaire
que vous orientez que sur trois éléments
la maîtrise médicale la meilleure
exploitation des gisements de d'économie
et le meilleur suivi des traitements moi
je vois rien de disruptif alors que vous
parlez de que vous vous permettez d'être
je vois finalement le la reprise d'un
modèle qui craque parce que justement il
y a une crise mais qui ne remet pas en
cause complètement
la réflexion est si c'est ça si vous si
vous préconisations structurent autour
de ces trois de ces trois éléments je je
j'ai quelques doutes sur sur l'aspect
disruptif que vous que vous que vous
voudriez que vous voudriez avoir
longtemps
travaillé sur les volumes
sans avoir sans vous interdire une
réflexion sur les prix et je trouve que
c'est très réducteur par rapport aux
propres constats que vous faites sur la
complexité du système etc et que dans
votre mission il y a quand même le
renforcement de notre tissu productif
l'attractivité des territoires pour les
industriels et la relooker
relocalisation de produits de santé
stratégique et puis il y a un thème qui
est quand même important l'équilibre et
l'équité dans la répartition des efforts
donc comment ça ça se conjugue et sans
vouloir trahir parce que si vous pouvez
pas aller plus loin on le comprendra et
on arrêtera là l'échange parce que c'est
s'il est pas s'il n'est pas mûr au
niveau de vos réflexions on peut le
comprendre on peut le comprendre et vous
ne le ferez par écrit au moment de de
rendu et on peut tout à fait le
l'entendre ça mais en tout cas c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça
parce que nous aussi on en est
pratiquement une trentaine d'auditions
je pense ou plus 40 50 donc beaucoup
plus des déplacements sur le terrain on
a rencontré des entreprises etc donc je
veux dire que on commence à avoir un peu
les tenants et les aboutissants de la
question et ce qui nous intéresse c'est
surtout d'être dans la dans la dans la
proposition parce que on va c'est pas un
exercice universitaire qu'on fait donc
si on peut pas aller plus loin on va pas
plus loin on vous en tiendra pas rigueur
pour autant on constatera mais voilà
donc moi un pas de remise en cause mais
moi je trouve que c'est très ce que vous
dites et très très révélateur de la
composition quand même je suis pas bon 2
oui c'est ça c'est que vous êtes dans le
dans la dans la mission il y en a cinq
sur six qui viennent qui proviennent
quand même du monde de du business enfin
de pas au sens péjoratif du terme mais
en tout cas c'est c'est une c'est une un
acte un acteur parmi d'autres quoi donc
ils sont très donc de fait je vois pas
où vous pouvez être disruptif mais vous
pouvez me contredire si vous avez les
moyens de me contredire aujourd'hui
et
deuxièmement je
j'aimerais bien que vous nous disiez un
mot de ces de ces éléments que je viens
de citer sinon je pense que voilà
permettez peut-être leur troisièmement
la première excusez-moi mais
on n'est pas là pour débattre sur la
composition de la mission encore une
fois que la Magali Dany nous ne sommes
pas responsables de la façon de la
mission était constituée et vous avez
dans la mission de deux personnes qui
sont prophétiques qui ont un pinceau de
professionnel de santé enfin qui ont une
expérience formation en matière de santé
je suis le seul à avoir un parcours
exclusivement dans le domaine de
l'entreprise ou quasiment exclusivement
dans le domaine de l'entreprise et on a
quatre personnes qui ont un parcours
dans l'administration dans la haute
administration et de santé donc on a des
gens qui sont me semble-t-il et nos
débats ne sont en aucun cas conduit
comment dire dirigé par l'un d'entre
nous et comme la souligné magaliste un
débat qui est une discussion qui est
collégiale ce qui explique aussi
peut-être au terme de ces termes parlent
tout à fait au terme parce qu'on en a
encore un certain nombre devant nous au
moins une vingtaine ils ont une
vingtaine
que aujourd'hui nous sommes nous soyons
dans ce travail de synthèse et
effectivement je suis désolé je ne vous
décevoir je le comprends mais nous avons
encore besoin on nous avons passé plus
de encore une fois plus de 200 heures
d'audition diverses et aujourd'hui nous
sommes en train de travailler sur une
dizaine de chapitres qui vont au-delà de
ce que j'ai pu dire bien entendu et qui
et qui vont couvrir les différents
champs pas strictement ce que j'ai
évoqué cela dit puisque notre mission
était quand même cela dit
puisque notre mission était quand même
beaucoup sur l'équilibre des produits de
santé à travers à la fois l'accès et en
même temps les aspects industriels et en
même temps l'équilibre budgétaire la
question de la régulation et la façon
dont ces leviers sont activés étaient
essentiels et donc aujourd'hui de fait
il faut qu'on se penche sur chacun on se
penche c'est un des chapitres mais sur
chacun de ces trois leviers que sont une
régulation par les prix qui était très
utilisé une régulation relative par les
volumes beaucoup moins utilisés que ce
qu'elle peut être ailleurs et de
maîtrise médicalisée et une régulation
disons par la structure qui est un
levier de structure qui a été
relativement moins employé alors ce sera
l'objectif infini et d'arriver à un
système qui permet d'assurer l'accès au
traitement mature et au traitement
innovant et je pense que cette réponse
sur la régulation sera un des un des
leviers importants oui
j'ai peut-être essayé de préciser quand
même les chaussures sur la maîtrise
médicalisée est-ce que vous allez
proposer un accroissement du reste à
charge des patients qui est en France le
plus faible des pays de l'OCDE ma
deuxième question vous parlez de réduire
les volumes
alors que l'on sait que seulement 46%
des Français et essentiellement je dis
bien française ce sont les hommes qui
sont en bonne santé à 65 ans contre plus
de 75% en Suède et là je me réfère à un
rapport de ma collègue qui ici présente
Mélanie et vosgel sur la sécurité
écologique
et ma troisième question est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à l'idée qui appliquée au
Royaume-Uni au-delà d'un certain âge un
patient finalement n'est plus éligibles
à certaines thérapies
voilà trois questions précises et là
encore on est sur une commission
d'enquête donc vous pouvez effectivement
avoir des des réserves parce que c'est
en direct mais après vous pouvez
répondre par par écrit et nous gardons
évidemment les éléments que vous nous
deux que vous nous donnez mais il y a
quand même des réponses à apporter je
vous remercie
peut-être quelques éléments sur ces
trois questions importantes sur la
maîtrise médicalisée nous ne nous
aurions pas vers une augmentation du
reste à charge des patients c'est pas
comme ça que nous concevons la maîtrise
médicalisée aujourd'hui des dépenses
d'assurance maladie quand je parlais de
solutions disruptives elles peuvent
elles pourront peut-être porter et je ne
veux pas après en T encore sur ce que
seront les propositions de la mission
mais on a effectivement un intérêt
poussé sur la les pratiques
professionnelles sur le respect
des
par les professionnels des
recommandations de bonnes pratiques sur
des consommations de soins qui sont
élevées sur la polypathologie des
personnes âgées sur la polie médication
pardon des personnes âgées sur l'ampleur
des accidents de tipiatrogènes en France
donc oui on a un sujet autour des
prescriptions oui on a un sujet autour
de la consommation de médicaments qui
posent des problèmes de santé publique
qui est donc là l'approche
finalement plus santé publique qui
économique mais en réalité voilà on
considère que les les enjeux sont liés
l'un ayant un impact sur l'autre donc
oui on est sur la volonté d'aller
rechercher des des gardes déficients à
la fois en qualité et en dépense sur la
les pratiques professionnelles donc
notre sujet porte plus sur les pratiques
professionnelles que sur le reste à
charge des patients pour le dire très
simplement avec des écarts de pratique
qu'il faut documenter qu'il faut
rechercher et sans doute des solutions
qui sont à trouver dans différentes
sphères qui relèvent des sciences
sociales car lavent de la formation des
professionnels de santé de la
culturation d'un certain nombre de
sujets et aussi de d'une meilleure
information et appréhension des
recommandations qu'elles soient
publiques ou de je pense aux
recommandations scientifique ou à
d'autres recommandations qui peut être
produites qui peuvent être produites par
les sociétés savantes par exemple
sur les sur effectivement le niveau de
bonne santé ou moins bonne santé des
Français par rapport aux autres pays moi
je suis convaincu que l'état de santé
d'une population ne tient pas
exclusivement à l'accès aux médicaments
enfin ne tient pas au nombre de boîtes
de médicaments on va dire consommer
parfois ça peut même être l'inverse donc
en effet il y a sans doute un
des différences entre pays entre les
différents états de santé ou d'espérance
de vie en bonne santé entre entre les
pays mais la santé les déterminants de
la santé sont bien plus larges que l'axe
médicament bien plus large même que
l'accès aux soins ça tient aussi à des
causes environnementales sociétales qui
sont importantes donc je voilà
effectivement notre système de santé
notre dispositif de prise en charge
notre régime des ALD permet de couvrir
des besoins de santé important mais il y
a bien d'autres facteurs qui rentrent en
ligne de compte juste ajouter un point
parce que vous avez
excusez-moi le
budget par français qui était la France
était connue historiquement pour être un
des premiers pays mondiaux si ce n'est
le premier en matière de consommation de
produits de santé ce budget a baissé
aujourd'hui la France est absolument
dans la moyenne et en particulier en
Europe le la raison pour laquelle ça
revanche ça a baissé le budget global a
baissé
par les effets de la régulation par les
effets des prix par les effets du
générique etc mais également mais le
volume le volume consommé continue de
baisser mais fait toujours partie le
nombre de ce qu'on appelle du CD
c'est-à-dire d'unité d'unité consommée
par français reste parmi les premiers
d'Europe et en fait seule l'Allemagne
est devant nous l'Allemagne progresse et
le but le nombre d'unités concernées par
français baisse mais reste un des
premiers un premier à des premiers
d'Europe et donc il nous semble que
c'est un sujet qui est important pas de
de faire de pouvoir assurer que le la
consommation
le nombre d'unités de produits de santé
soit probablement mieux encadré un point
qui est important c'est que nous avons
également observé que bien souvent c'est
les changements sont faits en France il
y a deux vous observez deux systèmes
très différents vous avez des systèmes
de type nordique ou de type allemand par
exemple qui sont des systèmes qui
fonctionnent par la contrainte le
médecin par la contrainte c'est-à-dire
que vous avez un budget un encadrement
quand vous avez en France plutôt un
système qui fonctionne par le par le
financement c'est à dire que vous voulez
typiquement prenons l'exemple du
générique le médicament générique est
insiste et c'est beaucoup développé en
France il y a substitution est-ce
qu'elle est les bonnes dans le
répertoire c'est aussi parce que les
pharmaciens s'ils sont mis et que les
pharmaciens ont été pour ça ils l'ont
fait aussi parce qu'ils y avait un
intérêt la question se posera sur les
bio similaires qui est une vague qui
arrive prochainement et sur lequel il
faut se poser la question de savoir
comment comment on l'aborde mais dans
d'autres pays d'autres et d'autres pays
ont fonctionné de façon différente un
médecin allemand un budget et quand il
le dépasse
doit rendre des comptes sur son budget
jusqu'à certains jusqu'à certains
moments donc on a un système qui a
fonctionné par
le excusez-moi par
par soutien financier disons beaucoup
plus que par contrainte on peut aussi se
poser la question de se dire quand on a
un soutien financier et ce qui doit
s'inscrire dans le temps quand le geste
est pris ou est-ce qu'une fois que on a
atteint le niveau que l'on souhaite on
peut considérer que ce soutien financier
se transforme autrement sur un autre
geste ou disparaît même donc c'est une
des c'est une c'est là aussi une
spécificité
est-ce que nos collègues des questions à
poser ou d'un non
c'est pas une question mais comme comme
vous êtes
à la rédaction finalement de de votre
mission que j'ai bien entendu que il y
avait des chapitres qui restaient
à compléter et qu'on a on a donc cette
audition moi je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que bien sûr il y
a nécessité de faire en sorte que il y
ait une consommation de médicaments qui
qui correspondent aux besoins de santé
de chaque patient et de chaque patient
donc il y a une nécessité d'encadrement
mais il me semble en tout cas dans
l'échange que nous avons nous avons eu
par rapport aux réponses que vous nous
avez apportées que il est quand même
plus facile de
d'explorer cette piste
qui financièrement n'engage pas l'état
plutôt que de remettre en cause le
système quand même qui est le système
économique dont vous avez dit vous même
tous les deux qu'il était à bout de
souffle donc j'attire juste votre
attention là-dessus c'est peut-être pas
votre votre comment dirais-je votre
propos principal mais en tout cas dans
le dans la restitution que vous nous
faites et dans la façon dont nous et je
crois qu'on a on est tous on a compris
la même chose attention en tout cas si
je puis me permettre après je n'ai aucun
aucun droit sur sur cette mission voilà
ni aucun pouvoir mais puisque on est on
est en audition j'attire juste votre
attention pour qu'il y ait pas un
déséquilibre parce que si un système est
à bout de souffle ça veut dire qu'il
faut le revisiter
peut-être un commentaire sur ce que vous
venez de dire à Madame la rapporteur au
sujet de la donc de cette maîtrise
d'évoluent par la maîtresse médicalisée
des dépenses mais aussi des prix qui
sont dans le dans le champ d'analyse de
la mission
nous sommes aussi dans un contexte
particulier où est annoncé une réforme
de la tarification des soins et une
réforme des parcours probablement avec
des travaux au long cours qui vont être
conduits mais qui pourraient produire
des des résultats intéressants sur ces
l'amélioration du parcours de soins des
patients et dans ce cas là nous sommes
attentifs assez au déroulement de ces
travaux puisque là on pourrait imaginer
des dispositifs de prise en charge qui
soient complètement rénovées qui ne
ressemblent pas à ce que nous
connaissons déjà qui pourrait inclure à
la fois des prises en charge liées des
prises en charge hospitalières
ambulatoire médicament enfin on pourrait
imaginer beaucoup de choses pour
améliorer les parcours des des patients
peut-être un deuxième commentaire à
faire sur un
un élément que nous n'avons pas
mentionné et qui est aussi au cœur de
nos de notre préoccupation c'est vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure le critère
industriel dans la fixation des prix il
y a aussi un critère tout à fait capital
nous semble-t-il c'est ce sont les
virales alors je crois qu'on se sont les
données de vie réelle qu'on a dû évoquer
dans nos propos liminaires mais ça nous
semble effectivement très important de
réfléchir à une meilleure prise en
compte des notes des données de vie
réelle que ce soit des données de
qualité de vie ou des données
médico-économiques pour l'évaluation
expost des produits de santé donc on est
en train de réfléchir au dispositif
d'analyser des dispositifs tels qu'ils
existent le recueil de données telles
qu'il existe les limites des des agences
pour en tenir compte et les peut-être
les exigences méthodologiques qui
doivent accompagner
l'amplification de ces de ces données et
de leur prise en compte dans les
mécanismes futurs de régulation
je crois qu'on a fait le tour de ce que
vous pouviez ou ce que vous vouliez ou
ce que vous étiez en mesure de nous dire
aujourd'hui donc je vais je vais lever
la séance je vous rappelle la
possibilité de nous faire de nous
communiquer des documents
complémentaires pour éclairer nos
travaux
or cette cette audition à proprement
parler qui est
en direct sur sur le site
et je voudrais dire à nos collègues que
la dernière audition aura lieu le jeudi
15 avec le ministre
je dis 15 à 9 heures pour clore
la série des auditions ce qui ne clôt
pas pour autant le travail à faire
puisqu'il faut rédiger et avoir des
préconisations mais l'objectif oui c'est
bien d'arriver à une présentation de nos
travaux dans la première quinzaine de
juillet voilà ben écoutez bonne
continuation pour votre votre travail
entendez quand même je pense le message
qu'on a essayé de passer parce que
travailler six mois pour rien remettre
en cause ce serait un petit peu un petit
peu frustrant pour tout le monde je
crois y compris pour pour vous en tout
cas je vous remercie de votre
participation et
après avec merci à vous merci